D
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
PRESIDENT BIDEN IN SAUDI ARABIA
CLAIMING HE IS TALKING TOUGH
WITH THE OIL-RICH DICTATORS OVER
THE MURDER OF JOURNALIST
KHASHOGGI AND LAUGHING OFF
QUESTIONS OVER HIS CONTROVERSIAL
FIST BUMP WITH THE COUNTRIES
CROWN PRINCE.
>> RESPECT TO THE MURDER OF
KHASHOGGI, RAISED AT THE TOP OF
THE MEETING MAKING IT CLEAR WHAT
I THOUGHT AT THE TIME AND WHAT I
THINK OF IT NOW.
I SAID VERY STRAIGHTFORWARDLY,
FOR AN AMERICAN PRESIDENT TO BE
SILENT ON AN ISSUE OF HUMAN RACE
IS INCONSISTENT WITH WHO WE ARE
AND WHO I AM.
>> BASICALLY SAID THAT HE WAS
NOT PERSONALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
IT.
I INDICATED THAT I THOUGHT HE
WAS.
YES.
>> YOU ARE GETTING UNDER FIRE
FOR YOUR FIST BUMP WITH THE
CROWN PRINCE.
I JUST WANT TO GIVE YOU A CHANCE
TO RESPOND TO THAT.
BUT HOW CAN YOU BE SURE THAT
ANOTHER INCIDENT OR MURDER LIKE
KHASHOGGI WILL NOT HAPPEN AGAIN?
>> GOD LOVE YOU, WHAT A SILLY
QUESTION, HOW CAN I BE SURE OF
ANY OF THAT?
IT'S BEEN THE PRESIDENT IS UNDER
ENORMOUS PRESSURE TO TAKE DOWN
GAS PRICES WITH THE TRIP AND
DEMOCRATS IN HIS OWN PARTY
GETTING TIRED OF HIS INFLATION
SPIN.
>> WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY IN
THE LEADERSHIP TO BE HONEST WITH
PEOPLE, TO NOT TRY TO SPIN THEM.
AND THEN WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO CHARGE
FORWARD.
IT DOES NOT MEAN THAT THERE IS A
SILVER BULLET ON FIXING
INFLATION.
I WANT TO BE STRAIGHT ABOUT
THAT.
AND I WANT TO SAY, HERE'S THE
PLAN.
>> Judge Jeanine: WAS AT ALL
FOR NOTHING?
AT LEAST ONE REPORT INDICATES
THAT JOE BIDEN WILL COME BACK
HOME WITH NO ANNOUNCEMENT ON
PRODUCING MORE OIL, BUT HAVE NO
WORRIES, WHILE HE MIGHT NOT GET
ANY MORE OIL, HE IS MAKING MOVES
ON GREEN ENERGY.
>> SAUDI ARABIA WILL ALSO
PARTNER WITH US ON CLEAN ENERGY
INITIATIVE.
FOCUSED ON CLEAN HYDROGEN,
SOLAR, AND NUCLEAR PROJECTS.
AND TO HELP THE U.S. CLEAN
INDUSTRY SETS GLOBAL STANDARDS.
>> WHAT WAS THE IMPACT OF THIS
VISIT?
>> I SUSPECT YOU WON'T SEE THAT
FOR A NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS.
I WILL SEE MORE WHEN WE SEE THE
PRICE CONSISTENT OF WHAT THEY
ARE PAYING FOR YOU ALL.
>> Judge Jeanine: SO, I WILL
START WITH YOU, GERALDO, THE
PRESIDENT HAS DONE EVERYTHING HE
CAN TO TRASH TO THE SAUDI USE
AND TO DESTROY AMERICAN ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
AND SO HE GOES OVER THERE, HAT
IN HAND TO ASK FOR MORE OIL
INSTEAD OF DELIVERING THE GOODS
THERE IS NO ANNOUNCEMENT WE ARE
GETTING MORE OIL, WHAT HE DOES
AS HE ANNOUNCES THAT WE ARE
GOING TO BE PARTNERS WITH
SAUDI ARABIA ON GREEN ENERGY.
WHAT IS WRONG WITH THIS MAN?
>> I THINK THAT IT IS A NOTE TO
SAY THE LEAST.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY HE WENT
THERE AND HAD TO GO THERE
KNOWING THAT HE IS BEING
CRITICIZED FOR EMPHASIZING
ELECTRIC VEHICLES AT A TIME
WHERE GAS PRICES ARE THROUGH THE
ROOF.
I WILL SAY THAT THE PRESIDENT
WITH GAS PRICES ARE TRENDING
DOWN, A COUPLE OF PENNIES EVERY
DAY.
AND IT HAS BEEN EVERYDAY FOR
ALMOST THE LAST MONTH NOW.
TO ME THE BIGGEST THING ABOUT
THIS VISIT CAME RIGHT IN THE
LAST HOUR OR TWO, THE
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT THERE WAS A
DEAL BETWEEN SAUDI ARABIA AND
ISRAEL WHERE THEY CLAIM TO LAND
VICE VERSA, THIS IS A HUGE DEAL.
THEY ARE THE KEYSTONE OF THE
ANTI-ISRAELI ARAB BLOCK.
IF WE CAN GET NORMALIZED
RELATIONS BETWEEN SAUDI ARABIA
AND ISRAEL, I THINK THAT THAT IS
A HUGE, HUGE STEP UP THESE
ISLANDS IN THE RED SEA.
A LOT OF TENSION OVER THE YEARS
AND WE NEED IT, THAT LOOKS LIKE
IT'S GOING TO BE IN THE PAST
RIGHT NOW.
IT DOES SEEM TO ME THAT THERE IS
MEANINGFUL PROGRESS, NOT ON THE
ENERGY PART IRONICALLY, MAY BE
BITTERLY IRONICALLY, BUT WHAT WE
NEED ON THE POLITICAL SIDE NOW
JOINING MANY OTHERS IN
NORMALIZING RELATIONS FOR THE
ABRAHAM ACCORD.
SPIN ON THE, SO WE DON'T REALLY
GIVE JOE BIDEN CREDIT FOR THIS?
THIS GUY CAN BARELY GET OVER
THERE AND DECIDE WHETHER HE IS
GOING TO SHAKE HIS HAND OR
FIST BUMP.
SO TO THE FIST BUMP, I WILL GO
TO YOU, TYRUS, WHAT IS WITH THE
FIST BUMP?
>> Tyrus: I DON'T KNOW, I
GUESS THE HANDSHAKE OR THE FIST
MOM, BECAUSE YOU'D PULL THE
FINGER BACK IT'S DIFFERENT.
IT'S LAUGHABLE AND I LIKE THE
FACT THAT HE SAID I DON'T
BELIEVE HIM, BUT HE TOLD ME HE
DID NOT DO IT, AND I SAID, I
THINK THAT HE DID NOT DO IT.
AND THE ONLY THING THAT MAKES A
PARTNER WITH US WITH CLEAN
ENERGY IS WHEN WILL THAT BE?
BECAUSE WE HAVE ENOUGH
PARTNERING WITH GREEN ENERGY.
WHEN ARE WE GOING TO SEE SOME
ACTUAL STUFF?
THAT WAS THE LONGEST SPEECH
ABOUT NOTHING AND THE FIST BUMP
WAS PROBABLY MORE ON THE OTHER
SIDE.
THE PRINCE IS LIKE, I DON'T WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE HIM, OKAY, HERE.
YEAH, HERE YOU GO.
SO THEY DID NOT COME OUT
TOGETHER WITH A GREAT
ANNOUNCEMENT.
THERE WAS NOTHING.
HE JUST CAME BACK AND SAID
BASICALLY EVERYTHING THAT HE WAS
GOING TO DO AND DID NOT REALLY
DO, BUT STAY TUNED.
>> Judge Jeanine: LOOKED LIKE
A PERFUNCTORY FIST BUMP, BUT
LAWRENCE, WHAT IS INTERESTING IS
THAT YOU SHOOK YOUR HEAD WHEN I
SAID THAT IT SEEMS LIKE HE IS
TRYING TO TAKE CRITICS FROM WHAT
HAS BEEN DONE BY OTHER
PRESIDENTS.
>> Lawrence: THEY ALREADY SET
THE STAGE FOR THESE NEGOTIATIONS
AND COUNTRIES SIGNED IN,
OBVIOUSLY A SECOND TERM, SO
THOSE NEGOTIATIONS ARE PUT
INTACT, THE SAME THING HE DOES
WHEN IT COMES TO THE VACCINE.
HE DID NOT HELP GET IT DONE, AND
JOE BIDEN IS AN OFFICE AND IT
WOULD BE THE SAME DEMOCRATIC
SYSTEM, BUT THERE IS A LOT OF
STUFF TO DEAL WITH AT THIS PRESS
CONFERENCE.
I WILL TAKE YOU BACK TO THE
TRUMP YEARS WHEN RUSSIA MEDDLED
IN OUR ELECTION.
AND EVERYBODY WAS TYPING UP AT
THE FIRST VISIT WITH
DONALD TRUMP WHEN HE WAS
SUPPOSED TO MEET VLADIMIR PUTIN.
IT'S INTERESTING TO NOTE THAT HE
HAD ALREADY PUT RECORD SANCTIONS
ON RUSSIA, SO HE GETS THERE AND
HE LOOKS HIM IN THE EYE AND HE
SAYS, JUST DON'T MEDDLE IN OUR
ELECTIONS.
THIS IS AFTER HE HAS ACTUALLY
TAKEN ACTION.
JOE BIDEN GOES AND THEY HYPED
THIS UP, THEN HE FIST BUMPS THE
GUY, I MEAN, THERE'S REALLY NO
ACTION BEING TAKEN.
THE FAMILY IS CRITICIZING HIM.
I AM JUST SAYING THAT TO THE
MEDIA WENT CRAZY OVER THIS
INCIDENT, YET THEY ARE PRETTY
SILENT WHEN IT COMES TO THIS.
BUT THERE IS SO MUCH HAPPENING
DOMESTICALLY HERE WHEN IT COMES
TO INFLATION.
YOU SEE THE PARTY ABANDONING HIM
RIGHT NOW.
YOU SEE THE DEMOCRATIC
STRATEGISTS, THEY DON'T WANT TO
BE INVOLVED WITH HIM.
YOU HEAR BACK CHANNEL TALK FROM
THE OBAMA'S THAT ARE TALKING IT.
BUT THERE IS NOT ENOUGH SAID
ABOUT THE JOB THAT HE IS DOING.
THEY ARE UPSET THAT THEY ARE
LOSING AND THE IDENTITY POLITICS
AND THE SPIN AND THEY THOUGHT
ROE V. WADE WAS GOING TO BE A
KILLER ISSUE.
AND IT JUST SIMPLY IS NOT
WORKING.
BUT WE SHOULD EXPECT THIS FROM
JOE BIDEN.
HE STAYED IN THE BASEMENT THE
MAJORITY OF THE TIME.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THE MEDIA
IS UP THERE, IT'S EXACTLY WHAT
HE SAID HE WAS GOING TO DO.
IF THIS IS ANY OTHER INDUSTRY,
IT WOULD'VE BEEN CONSIDERED
MALPRACTICE WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
THIS COUNTRY.
IT IS THE MEDIA'S JOB TO BE THE
WATCHDOG OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT'S NOT LIKE A LAWYER WHEN YOU
HAVE A BOARD OR A BAR TO
INVESTIGATE YOU.
IT'S NOT LIKE A DOCTOR TO HAVE A
STATE BOARD FOR TEACHERS.
THE WATCHDOG IS THE PRESS.
AND JOE BIDEN IS DOING EXACTLY
WHAT HE SAID HE WAS GOING TO DO,
WE ARE JUST HARMED IN THE
PROCESS.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU KNOW
WHAT, THE IDEA THAT EVEN THE
DEMOCRATS DON'T BELIEVE A WORD
THAT THIS PRESIDENT HAS SAID,
AND YET AS LAWRENCE SAID, THEY
DON'T CRITICIZE HIM.
THEY DON'T CRITICIZE HIM.
WHEN TRUMP WAS PRESIDENT, EVERY
DAY, HE IS A LIAR, HE IS A LIAR,
HE IS A LIAR.
>> Katie: PERSON I THINK THE
QUESTIONS FROM THE PRESS CORPS
ARE NEVER ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT WANT
ANSWERS ABOUT WHEN THEIR LIVES
ARE GOING TO GET BETTER AND WHEN
THINGS ARE GOING TO COST LESS
FOR THEM, BUT THE HEADLINE THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN DID NOT WALK
AWAY FROM THE MEETING WITH ANY
KIND OF AGREEMENT TO TALK MORE
OIL, HE HAS NO INTENTION OF
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWERING GAS
PRICES, BECAUSE THEY ARE
INTENTIONS --
THEY HAVE AN INTENTION TO
TRANSITION THE COUNTRY AWAY FROM
FOSSIL FUELS ONTO WHAT THEY
THINK IT'S GOING TO BE THIS NEW
ALTERNATIVE ENERGY UTOPIA.
SO THEY CAN'T LOWER GAS PRICES,
BECAUSE THAT WOULD RUIN THAT
AGENDA, OR THEY SAY, WELL, GUESS
IS TOO HIGH, YOU SHOULD BE
BUYING AN ELECTRIC CAR, AT THE
SAME TIME THEY ARE PUSHING THAT
AGENDA IN SAUDI ARABIA AND
CALIFORNIA TELLING ELECTRIC
VEHICLES NOT TO PLUG IN DURING
PEAK HOURS, BECAUSE THEY MAY
HAVE BLACKOUTS AND BROWNOUTS.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE IN THE DUTCH
PROTESTING BECAUSE THE
GOVERNMENT IS IN CRINGING ON
THEIR PERSONAL PROPERTY RIGHTS
TO PUSH THE GREEN AGENDA.
AND YOU ALSO HAVE EUROPE
ESSENTIALLY TURNING THE COAL
PLANTS BACK ON AN EMERGENCY
CRISIS WHEN IT COMES TO NATURAL
GAS BECAUSE OF WHAT RUSSIA HAS
DONE IN UKRAINE.
SO THE ALTERNATIVE ENERGY AGENDA
IS A VERY PAINFUL ONE, THEY HAVE
NO INTENTION OF REDUCING PRICES
AT THE PUMP AND IN TERMS OF
DEMOCRATS COMING TO TERMS BEFORE
AN ELECTION ABOUT HOW THINGS ARE
TOO EXPENSIVE ABOUT INFLATION,
WELL, THEY DID THIS.
THIS IS THEIR FAULT.
REPUBLICANS DID NOT VOTE FOR THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN THAT SHOT
INFLATION THROUGH THE ROOF.
THAT WAS ALL DEMOCRATS AND THE
PROBLEM WITH INFLATION IS IT
CAN'T PUT IT BACK.
SO VOTERS ARE LOOKING AT IT AND
SAYING, WHO DID THIS?
AND THEY ARE LOOKING AT THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> Judge Jeanine: IT IS JUST
LIKE THE PRESIDENT IS SAYING, WE
WILL HAVE A LITT